agt it's the semi-final so you know
anything can happen and things got
just a little too real for our favorite
germaphobe howie mandel
it's about to get a little weird howie
how are you doing after you were called
up
to participate and then all of a sudden
the guy sticks a camera down his throat
oh oh anytime in my existence that would
be disgusting
more now than ever oh my god is that in
there
keep your duck to yourself nobody needs
to see your duck
my child today we spoke with 31 year old
street performer brett loudermilk who
isn't concerned with the next level
gross factor holding him back tonight
he is the world's most famous germaphobe
there's not a better person to do
something crazy and gross to
i got the reaction that i expected
tonight just five of the 11 acts will
advance to next week's finals
and we're holding out for a simon
surprise five weeks after he was
sidelined with a broken back
what can you tell me is he gonna pop up
for the finals give me something
okay he's gonna come to the finale but
don't tell anyone
i would love to hide him before the
finale i felt like a little bit cheated
when he had the accident
and i will be very excited to have him
i know that it would be impossible for
him to sit for a whole episode because
that would be painful
they also say break a leg but they don't
get back
right don't break
you